if you're american and you think america
is the best country in the world can you
please give me a genuine reason why i
don't know how many times we've got to
tell y'all america is a third world
country in a gucci belt
we hate it here too
like
we don't want to be here
a third world country uh he says
lounging on his bed in what looks to be
a shower cap
recording a video on his 900 phone
which he'll upload using his internet
connection and then spend the day
scrolling the internet playing video
games eating whatever snacks he finds in
his mom's pantry yeah a third world
country hey ma can we get some meatloaf
since he does hate it here let me let me
just offer him a suggestion and i would
offer this suggestion to
anyone else who hates it here and hates
this country
um
you can leave get out
leave the country there there is no law
i got good news for you
no law requiring you to stay i wish
there was a law requiring you to leave
but there isn't why would you stay in a
place you hate